so today what are we looking at we're
looking at Republic before you guys
started out with Republic one where we
have these conversations between
Socrates and Symington s and a few other
people and we talked about what justice
was we're going to look at what justice
is according to Socrates and Plato now
and it's very different than what we saw
in book 1 and book 1 justice was you
know paying people back you know paying
good people back good things paying bad
people back bad things there was
actually a movie out there called
payback Mel Gibson where the whole point
of the movie is bad people get bad
things and that's the right thing to do
that wasn't gonna work you saw why
thumper Senecas comes out with this
might makes right kind of philosophy
whoever's in power gets to decide and
pose their views on everybody else
and that's the right way for things to
go and we saw some problems with that
too so Socrates was just about other
people's problems wasn't it it's not
really fair for him not to supply us
with some sort of positive idea what
justice is this is where he doesn't
before we get to that though we gotta
ask about the soul parts of the song and
I think part of what we ought to think
about here is you know not just taking
things at face value
okay talks about parts of the soul on
the city and all these things why is he
doing that why do we have to talk about
the soul if we want to know about
justice I mean first of all you're
talking about the soul they couldn't see
a solo any more back in Greek times as
ancient they couldn't see the soul any
more back then as we can't know there's
a lot of people who think that talking
about the soul is just a bunch of
nonsense right if I if I took a poll of
you right now and you don't have to
defend your position Airy
like that but I'm not gonna tell you
where I come down in this because I
don't want to spew the pole but
everybody has to go how many of you
believe that there's no such thing as a
soul all you've got is your body and
that's you and when your body dies that
it's over a few okay how many of you
believe that that you have some sort of
soul and that's going to last for all
eternity okay how many of you think of
that soul as something sort of like what
we see in movies where somebody gets hit
and they're dead and then you see this
kind of like ghostly form come out and
walk around and you can see through it
and they look at their body and they say
holy I'm dead nobody has that sort of
notion well that's pretty good
cartoons use that too why because it's
so difficult to represent this is the
question of what makes you you if you're
uncomfortable with the idea of the soul
you know because all sorts of
theological overtones think about your
personality what makes you you what
gives you the characteristics that you
have of being the kind of person that
you are for better or for worse probably
some parts better and some parts worse
nobody's perfect and no it's perfectly
terrible so why do we have to worry
about this in order to know what what
justice is
well think about personalities are some
people with their personalities are some
people more reliable than others yes or
no yeah and that's just part of their
personality right that's not just
something that they happen to be one day
and it changes completely to the next
matter if it if it does change we say
something something is happened
something has really affected them what
else there's some other aspects of our
personality that might have to do with
whether somebody is doing the right
thing or wrong yeah do they have a sense
of conscience yeah
because most of us if you have that
sense of conscience do all of us follow
it no III don't know all the time myself
some people do follow it all some people
don't actually have that little voice of
conscience we call those sociopaths and
they are extremely dangerous because
they are only interested in satisfying
their own desires yeah everybody else is
just there to satisfy their desires and
if you get in their way they will they
have no compunction about doing anything
whatsoever to you and they're actually
not treatable there's no way to fix them
psychologically because they don't care
what other people actually think they
can't sense that most of us do have a
conscious I'm gonna presume everybody in
here does so you're all familiar with
that experience whether you follow it or
not that's part of what determines
whether you're gonna be just or not
that's part of your personality as part
of your soul what are the sort of things
that drive people to
two bad things let's take in justice
let's not take justice think about your
own experience or about movies you've
seen or shows you've all seen later you
know hundreds of thousands of hours now
maybe tens of thousands of hours of
shows which people do bad things
think about reality shows yeah sure
pressure okay what kind of pressures
just like pressure within yourself okay
those are two good examples of things
that move people to do things maybe
sometimes for good maybe some tension or
prevent peer pressure peer pressure is
stemming from a desire to be liked by
other people right which is a natural
part of your your makeup as a human
being you have a desire to be liked
every one of those does they can steer
us and good ways against doers and bad
ways and then you talked about something
else that's interesting instead of just
worrying about what other people think
you worry about what you think about
yourself right
maybe you feel guilty if you don't
measure up to some standards that you've
imposed on yourself yeah actually I do
that when I I have it to do list and
every day I don't get my to-do list I'm
now the rational thing would be to put
less stuff on my to-do list Linda I
don't do that yet I keep putting all
that stuff on there and I get about half
of it done and then I feel sort of
feeling good about the stuff that I
actually do get done I tend to feel bad
about the stuff but don't get done and
then okay that's that's a psychological
fact how might that affect my life well
maybe I get short with my fiance because
I'm feeling pressure right
or maybe I decide I'm not going to do
something with somebody
I have to get this stuff done all right
that maybe I should take it easy more
often maybe that would be a good thing
for me to do maybe I would be a better
person if I did that sort of thing what
else drives us to do bad things
sensation very good yeah
we have desires for all sorts of things
and they're objects of sense and why do
we involve ourselves with them because
it feels good chocolate tastes good
coffee tastes good once you get used to
when you're a kid beer doesn't taste
good but then you know learner you're
does taste good if you have a taste for
not beer we won not wine probably
something else right even make special
drinks for people who don't like those
spritzers things like that all different
kinds of foods attract us other
pleasures money yeah money's a little
bit different right that one present
everything well that's not a physical
pleasure though I mean you can you can
take out a dollar bill and you could you
should look you at it and you could say
hi great art you know great workmanship
and I suppose you could like you know oh
it smells so good
can't eat it dry but what else
so sight and sound feel you could
crinkle it but a particularly nice sound
I'd rather listen to music myself so
money money by itself doesn't actually
provide much pleasure maybe you know
gold coins too because I'm pretty well
that gets you stuff that can provide
pleasure okay very good
yeah money is a go be dream money is a
me
to get you all sorts of other things
then there's lots of possessions that we
have we have desire for money we don't
desire if we're not crazy we don't
desire money just for this one say we
desire it because of the good things we
think it's going to give us right you
can just go on you know down the list
all the things that people are willing
to say why or cheat or steal or hurt
other people for there are people who
will hurt each other in order to get
clothing there are people you know once
you get into talking about sex there's
all sorts of ways in which people screw
up their lives isn't there you know we
have a whole industry that sort of
caters to that but I'm not just doing
what the porn industry I'm talking about
like advertising you know they realize
that sexuality and the desires of having
sex are thinking about having sex or
imagining sex are so powerful that they
can just suggest something I'll connect
it to some product that's not connected
to sex whatsoever except in a purely
accidental way and you can sell it right
think about beer commercials there's
some beer commercials where it's a bunch
of guys out camping and they're having a
great time around the campfire but how
do most beer commercials tell ago your
experience yeah exactly why do they do
that
yeah I know now now think about this for
a minute
rationally all of you who watched beer
commercials you've all seen probably
thousands of them did you ever think to
yourself that this sort of line of
reasoning can you say you know and then
if you know if you're a woman think
about this in terms of of men and you
can think of other products right in
this commercial buying this beer gets
these guys who are kind of an average
looking a whole bunch of hot girls to
hang around with and they're probably
like you know they seem to be very
friendly with these girls these girls
seem to be very friendly with them I'm
willing to bet there's a good chance
that they're going to get to have sex
with them you know so if that works for
them it must be likely to work for me if
I don't screw it up in some way so I
should probably drink Coors or a buck or
pick whatever you want does anybody
actually sit there and reason out this
way when they're watching them I don't
know why you're gonna be read to us and
we actually make fun of those yeah yeah
that's not gonna you know that's not
gonna influence me that's stupid but it
does work doesn't it so it must be
hitting us on some sort of level that's
bypassing reason it must be appealing to
some other part of our personality or
soul in a way that gets us to do things
because you know there's a reason why
advertisers use sex to sell things
because it actually does work
effectively
why exactly it works that there's a
different question let's think about how
how Plato
deals with this now I'm actually not
going to talk that much about the city
because you know this reading has to do
with the city and how the soul is like a
city and all that sort of stuff and the
Guardians and the lesser guardians and
the trades people let's just stick with
the parts of the soul what we know that
we we have we have feelings right every
one of us feelings possible probably
you're right
and you have desires and you have some
desires that Plato calls epithets if you
didn't you die there was a really
interest in casing I heard about one
time NPR and one of these kind of shows
where they explore these things in great
detail about a man who whose body quit
producing touch and this is supposed to
show you how about the physical doesn't
actually matter with them
testosterone all of you produce it if
you didn't you'd be really screwed up
who produces more testosterone than men
and men tension right because that's
part of what makes us mannish if you
want to change your gender or something
like that and you're you're a woman you
want to up your testosterone if you
whether you want to lower it if you're
trying to change a guy
all of us have testosterone testosterone
is linked to desire not just sexual
desire the desire in gentlemen think
about all the different things that we
desire we went through a few of them
things that we eat things that we taste
we desire
you know I'm actually on the way home
tonight I was I was considering buying
one of those those deli pizzas you know
taking that home because I've got a lot
of work to do and I don't feel like
cooking dinner and those taste really
good and I can almost you know if I
imagined it to myself I can almost
imagine what that's gonna taste like
instead I'm gonna get Chinese because my
fiance is not feeling well and hot sour
soup makes her feel better I like hot
sour soup Tim I'm gonna be like that
sour soup none of you like hot sour soup
it's all good especially having cold
days yeah and I can imagine that all
right I can begin to desire why do I
desire that sort of thing well that's
what's going on my soul but also partly
what's going on in my body if you don't
have any testosterone you quit desiring
things altogether this guy there was
something wrong with his body as his
glands he stopped producing it and he
would just lay in bed all day long and
this is gonna kind of gross you out but
for his meals he was perfectly happy
eating like Wonder Bread with some
mayonnaise on it and that and that was
great and he didn't feel like there was
anything wrong luckily he had a
girlfriend and she like you know what's
going on with you and he said that his
experience he had no attachments to
anything else and he would walk around
in his sense looking at everything was
that's beautiful that's beautiful that's
beautiful but there was no actual
appreciation of the beauty of things as
soon as we start to have desires they
start to draw us towards things things
that we consider beautiful or attractive
or desirable or enjoyable pleasurable
you want even some things that are
painful can become pleasurable too right
they can become something that somebody
needs think about runners or other
people who like to work out a lot
after a while they come to crave that
stimulation their body needs it Plato
would say there slowly all sorts of
appetites that you can think of why
don't you just follow them all the time
I mean if you did you wouldn't be in
this classroom you'd be out there eating
or sleeping or having sex or running or
who knows what playing the dog basking
in the Sun there's no Sun today but no
that's a pleasurable thing what what
else has to be in the soul in order for
you to wind up being here
why aren't you stop there having fun and
for a few of you you know doing
philosophy is fine and you know is this
your idea of a good time there are many
more pleasurable things than this
we talked about conscience earlier right
conscience opposes often what our
desires your aunt the text tells us tell
us labels not going to talk about
conscious what she's gonna talk about
reason what got you here is that you
think it's better for you to be here
than not to be here right why do you
think that so we will get behind them at
work okay that's a pretty you know high
low high level high word way of thinking
because it involves all sorts of other
concepts too doesn't it getting behind
what's wrong with getting behind in your
work okay get out of school maybe there
would be a good thing you know I mean if
you get out of school then you can hang
out and just you know drink beer and
play Nintendo all day or whatever you
know current Playstation is sort of
dating myself you know I mean why not do
that
well you reason out that that's not
what's ultimately good for you why don't
you want to drink why don't why don't
any of you want to drop out of school
besides the fact you mom
exactly you put off having some pleasure
now because you're thinking that it's
gonna be better for you down the line
right and there's some pleasures that
that's deferments of gratification
because we call it there's some
pleasures that you may be attracted to
but a part of yourself says whoa
what's wrong with me I shouldn't be
desiring man all right everybody's had
something like that in their lifetime
everybody's got something where they
they said to themselves that's not a
good thing for me to want that much or
want this way or wanting this form what
did that worry that was reason it's good
thing you've got it isn't
is that all there is to your soul when
it was Plato say there is there another
part some psychologists would say no
Aristotle we will look at in the coming
weeks he's going to say you have a
rational part and they appetite avert of
all our desires part let's play those
say what's in your soul
well we're going to get through the
virtues well what this could be a good
way what are the virtues that he
actually talked about in in book for
justice right what else or some other
virtues yeah
okay very good wisdom is gonna have to
do with our rational part temperance
gonna have to do that courage where does
that fit are you courageous with your
rational part with your reason is your
is your reason sort of like a cop
standing up to the the evildoer
or there's your reason for play-doh more
like the wise person sitting there and
saying you know really you shouldn't do
this
it is City there are two different sets
of people aren't they you've got the
rulers and the rulers aren't the
enforcers nor do the rulers protect the
city from outside threats you yeah
according to Plato you have a part of
yourself that protects you from outside
threats and can also react against your
desires and appetites he calls this the
passionate or the spirited part of the
soul
cars these are all you how many of you
getting everybody should raise their
hand because all of you to get angry
right telling me you don't get angry or
making stuff up because everybody gets
angry they stifle it we can pretend we
didn't get angry but we all together can
you never be angry with yourself I'm
even better angry with yourself why
you're like getting mad at yourself yes
you're frustrating maybe thought you
made the wrong decision something better
mm-hmm you made the wrong decision or
you could have done something better and
why didn't you let me followed some
desire you know if you get mad at
yourself for being overweight like I am
it's because you followed your desire to
eat more than you should not just once
not just twice but over and over and
over again okay if you get mad at
yourself for giving in to temptation to
let me take a you know sort of common
relationship thing all of you know
somebody who's been in a relationship a
sexual relationship with somebody who's
bad news for them right maybe the sex is
good but the relationship itself is bad
they're abusive they they exploit them
you know
sponge money off of them and things like
that let me say I'm gonna break up with
them but then they don't stick to them
if they don't stick to it's because of
their desires right it's not good reason
to limit X this reason is the law is the
part saying break up with them if they
can angry at themselves because of that
it's that spirited part that's the part
with which you
we did angry when you get angry at other
people why did you get angry what's
going on there yeah they don't like
disappointed you or they didn't like
they didn't act the way you wanted them
to ask okay
you've the frustrated you that
disappointed you you do you get angry at
people when you feel that what they did
was okay no you feel that they violated
some norm they let you down when they
shouldn't have let you down they treated
you in a way that you didn't like
because you're not deserving of that
that's the spirited part that's
defending you from outside threats it's
sort of like the soldiers that have to
get you know worked up when they go into
battle remember at the time that these
guys are are thinking about this you
actually had to run a sword through
somebody or spear through somebody so
you had to be you know you couldn't push
a button you had to be pretty excited
yeah and cops and firefighters and
people like that still have to do things
along those ones they have to get
themselves into the moment in order to
to do what they need to do to protect
people to protect itself to protect the
city so you have these three parts to
your soul and these correspond to two
virtues so they don't talk about this he
talks about rinche and he talks about
moderation and he doesn't tell you that
much about wisdom in this bar but what
is wisdom mean it means not just knowing
what the right thing to do is or what's
good
for you it's being able to think it out
because is it enough for you to it's and
there's no a bunch of rules or a bunch
of ideas you will actually have to think
them out over the course of your life
and it's always difficult to figure out
which one to apply at which point but if
you actually are able to give yourself
good counsel then you have wisdom does
everybody have that not everybody and it
has to develop over time these these
virtues we talked about this a little
bit last class
they're now produced in one day they're
not produced just by taking a pill
they're not produced by signing up for a
program they have to be produced by
practice by doing it over and over again
until it becomes part of your your
nature till it becomes worn into your
soul becomes a part of your personality
or your character so if you if you're an
impulsive person and you'd like it to be
different if you'd like to you know
think about things before you get into
them you have to practice that you have
to make that a habit which means you
probably have to break an old habit
what does he tell us about courage he
does tell us something what do you think
courage is what is courage feelings yeah
yeah
yeah and that's oh that's a pretty
common definition of courage
thanks to your fears what does it mean
to face your fears okay overcome
something you're you're uncomfortable
with how do you do that you do that just
like in your armchair okay these are all
common ways in which we talk about in
our society stepping outside of your
comfort zone which generally means
you're either stuck in a situation where
you put yourself into a situation if you
if you have fears of snakes
you can watch the Discovery Channel all
you like but that's probably not going
to help you face your fears what do you
have to do yeah I guess actually get out
there and go see a snake
yeah you might and it might have to be
by Processing's you know it might be the
snake is across the room from you and
you know that's okay and you do feel
fear but you face up to it right and
then eventually it's going to culminate
and you handling the snake you know and
then you're not going to do that right
at the start think about war right think
about basic training or boot camp for
Marines what do we do to soldiers and
Marines and to a lesser extent people in
the Navy and the Air Force Coast Guard
we break them down and we spent a lot of
time scaring the hell out of them and
making them do things that are very
physically arduous and yelling at them
and we get them to be able to go out to
a battlefield where people are going to
shoot at us that's a crazy thing to do
isn't it or is it a courageous thing to
do everybody should be afraid of getting
shot right
what is courage for for Plato it's more
than just facing up to you the feeling
of fear that's developing a kind of
understanding a sense of the opinion
respecting things to be feared courage
as a kind of salvation salvation not in
the eschatological I'm being saved I'm
going to heaven kind of sense but at
keeping something safe like preserving
something letting like for instance I
saved this by putting it in the closet
and not just throwing it over the back
of my car and keeping moths from eating
it you know we save things by putting
them on the refrigerator you can also
save things in your your soul and what
are you saving if your current is you're
courageous the opinion respecting things
to be feared what is actually to be
feared when you face up to your fears
part of what you're doing is you're
learning that the things that you are a
friend of do you think are gonna kill
you or destroy you aren't really that
terrifying again you know with the
soldiers and basic training why do they
go through all these drills why do they
a for instance I think they still
probably do this why do they gas them
that was a terrible part of basic
training you go into a gas chamber full
of to your guests you have a gas mascot
works you know you put it on right and
then they tell you all right take your
mask off and you have to do it that's
part of getting from basic training and
your long start filling up with this
this crap that makes you feel terrible
and your eyes start tearing and your
nose starts running and you might puke
or you know all sorts of other things
started happening to you why do they do
that well to teach you that it's not
because it isn't me actually that bad
compared to some of the things that
could happen to you it's really not that
bad so if you see you know a cloud that
sort of thing coming at you and it's not
nerve gas which will do horrible things
to you you can take it
that's pretty with courage is is knowing
what you can take it's knowing about
things that are scary and because you
know about being able to stand up to
them if you know that let's think let's
think about bullies right big common
topic these days if you know that if you
stand up to a bully where they most
likely then do there's a difference you
can say like a bully enough [ __ ] bug if
you stand up to them you're in trouble
we'll stop there but most of the people
who mess with you aren't I really
thought the bullies what happens if you
actually stand up to a boy you've all
seen this right at least once or twice
what happens when some kid is handed up
then tells the bully to offer pops it
back off and usually they stay backed
off don't they if you know that's about
human nature isn't it a lot easier the
next time around to confront a bully
played on the stain that courage is not
just a disposition a habit it's also a
kind of knowledge it's a it's a
knowledge that doesn't pertain so much
to
laughter you know reason but to the
spirited part it's something that you
would in some sense feel rather that be
able to articulate explicitly what's
moderation
she also this also gets called
temperance or self-control
once again think about all those
pleasures all those things that draw us
that we talked about earlier food drink
sex sleep pleasures of the eyes some
people some people get attracted to well
you know or think about the things
people collect and they get obsessed
about you know some of them I have a
hard time understanding I saw like stamp
collecting no no offense anybody here if
you're a stamp collector I just I don't
see what people get out of it your
desires do they have any limits for them
by themselves if you were given the
opportunity let's you know there's a
pleasure center right and some drugs hit
it just like that and that's why people
take drugs because it feels so good but
afterwards there's a thought experiment
let's say that you could have an implant
put into your brain
that would stimulate that pleasure
center constantly so the best mention
the best feeling that you can your life
so far you know whatever it happens to
be now imagine that the rest of your
life you have to work you don't do
anything you know to go back to school
you just have this chip put back there
or an electrode put back there and it's
too
constantly how many of you would pick
that life it'd be tempting wouldn't it
what would hold it back from it this is
this it's not your appetites because
your appetites would be saying oh yeah I
want that cuz that's all they know right
that's not the better part of you it is
something that's important because if
you don't have that the tights you won't
drink you won't die but how much food do
you actually need you need enough to get
big everything every one of the shoes
you're a thinner than I am which is
which wasn't the case where I thought
before interesting there are certain
limits right do you need the food that
you eat to be very rich all the time
it's that good for you well usually the
sugar there's I guess sugar and one
other thing what makes food taste with
it yeah yeah and actually you do need
some fat in your diet if you go the
other to the other extreme
you're probably screwing yourself up
because your brain needs fat to work and
other parts your body needs that too but
there are certain limits aren't there
there's there's a not enough and there's
a too much it's sort of like Goldilocks
and the three bears
you all remember that story you know you
go and moderation is like that not too
much not too little not too hot not too
cold you can think about this with think
about this within enjoyment like
watching television how many of you
watch TV or you watch TV shows through
something like Hulu or Netflix or
through your your console or something
you watch movies or you know you watch
web shows all of you watch something how
many hours do you think you should watch
watching 6 hours a day the good amount
why not yeah well cuz basically you're
just sitting around when he could be out
getting active that's pleasant isn't it
it pleasant but I mean it's not healthy
ya know your appetites don't don't tell
you that as a matter of fact all of you
know that temptation you've just watched
a show and they always have something
like about what's coming next but you're
using in Hulu and you've got auto play
you know exactly what's coming next the
next episode are you gonna sit there and
watch the next show or not sometimes
you'll sit there you've got the remote
and you your channel sir I'm just going
to see if there's anything guy what's
going on there your appetite is telling
you hey this is good this is this is fun
I enjoy this let's do this let's keep
doing that reason if it's working we'd
be telling you no you shouldn't maybe
you know go do something and it works
that way forever any pleasure that you
can think of we're solely for sex it
works for conversation could you spend
too much time reading a lot of people
enjoy reading right can you spend too
much time reading even that can become
something that is not moderate something
that's in modern now here's where it
gets really interesting the appetites by
themselves can't figure out this part of
your soul can't figure out what those
limits should be reason figures does
reason make that happen
it's always listened to reason
no they usually say screw you I'm gonna
do what I want to do I'm gonna steer the
human being I need every one of you this
one in order for a reason which only
just gives you advice to make itself
heard by the appetites it needs that
spirited part it needs that force of
will and those two together can impose
some order of the appetites and if they
do that long enough how many of you have
changed a habit in your lifetime
Avandia what was it like well the first
couple days of changing any habit how
did you feel tempted and then how did
that how'd that make you feel annoying
exactly now we're starting to get really
into it when when somebody quit smoking
for example are they fun to be around no
not even if they have a nicorette gum or
the patch or anything like that right
because they want that thing there their
appetites are in moderate how does it
after a while though when you don't have
these cravings whose temptations rising
yeah that's a good way to put it you
start to get used to it the appetites if
they're trained they become moderate
they they quit demanding so much
likewise if you know the spirited part
can go wrong too
then if you get angry it's a lot of time
at the wrong people too much you stay
angry too long yeah that's something you
don't do it somebody else does this you
know that would be if the spirited part
is not actually taking its direction
from reason either that's a problem to
the rational part by itself can
sometimes end up getting sort of roped
in just to try to figure out what the
best thing to do for satisfying the aims
of these the spirited part by the way is
also concerned with your self-respect
how you view yourself how other people
do and that can that can get a little
bit out of hand - can it if you need
everybody in the world to respect you
how's that going to work
ii ii happen
did you demand that from everybody your
and you use your reason just to try to
figure out how can I get people though
you know I think I'm a great guy to look
up to me you're probably a disorder in
things the ideal order is that reason
tells the spirited part you know and the
appetite a part of what to do not that
these things impose their demands on
some reason and when you have things
arranged like that then actually justice
a just person somebody who does the
what's the right thing because they
recognize that it's the right thing you
may do so habitually and they do so for
the right reason they do so Plato saying
because their soul is properly
integrated if you find yourself being
upset with yourself a lot if you find
yourself being sort of split against
yourself if you find yourself sometimes
not you know being able to stick to
something because one part of your soul
wants to go this way the other part
wants to go this way then you probably
don't have your soul completely
integrated you're not you know you're
not in good order and that would be
expected in this society wouldn't it
because there's all sorts of people out
there and parts of our culture that are
there precisely to screw you up you know
we talked about advertising is the
advertising gonna gonna put your soul on
the right stage no it's gonna inflame
your desires as much as possible because
that's how we sell things it's gonna try
to get you to not think about what the
better thing is to do
one thing that you could ask yourself if
you start to see things this way what
about your friends the people that you
surround yourself with are they steer
you in the right way are they
reinforcing you in seeing what's really
good for you and then making yourself do
it or are they facilitating you and
doing things that you know aren't good
for you if you have a drinking buddy
they're probably not going to be
somebody who's telling you you know
reason would say because they're a
drinking buddy they exist only so that
you can have fun right if you if you
want to be well integrated if you want
to have a happy life a plate I would say
you have to have these things in harmony
with each other because you have all of
these you have appetites you have a
spirited part you have reason so we
could ask is this actually true I'm
gonna put that aside for the moment and
just think about it let's say it is true
let's say Plato's got it right then how
many of you right now are unhappy with
the way in which these things are
arranged in your life I don't why nobody
else is nobody else's felt like they're
not completely integrated like they
sometimes do things and don't quite
realize why they did them that way or
they get too angry or they find
themselves doing things that they know
aren't good for them and then end up
saying kind of astone I'm willing to bet
that more
but if that's the case what would Plato
say you on again how would you go about
fixing yourself yeah we have all sorts
of ways to fix ourselves just society by
self-help books watch dr. Phil we're the
psychiatrist takes me antidepressant
give impulse control problems you drunk
for that I think I would see you
actually have to work on yourself
and Plato who thinks that in the kind of
society that we lived in you're likely
to find yourself 10 screwed up we don't
live in an ideal society what's what's
good about that though is that there's a
plan for how you might actually think
about the next class we're going to look
at another champ another book yeah we're
gonna look at what we're doing in
studying philosophy of the cave so make
sure to take a look at if you get a
chance we'll get some of those videos
that I
I actually like show you the allegory of
the cave being played outside when
you're when you're doing this think
about all this
that's gonna happen every time yeah
what's metaphysics I saw that okay
metaphysics that's a good question and
I'll tell you a funny story there was a
son I'm in graduate school and I'm
taking one of my first classes and I
signed up for the professor begins the
class by saying I'm not sure why all of
you are in here but I just want to make
something really clear from the start
this won't have anything to do with
crystals or past lives or any of that
sort of stuff that people call that
metaphysics but this is a different kind
of metaphysics this is philosophy that's
sort of stuff you can go down to the
hippie fair and you know do it do it
whatever you like and you know I
actually you know knew what metaphysics
was at that point but he had to say that
because if you googled metaphysics you
will see all this stuff about crystals
and tarot cards and all that come up and
there's a reason for them metaphysics in
the philosophical sense means a study of
ultimate reality study of what lies
behind appearances so thinking about
what things are actually made of right
what being is what are the various types
of being it's very abstract and it takes
a lot to do so now all these these other
things that people comment because
explain they kind of are connected to
metaphysics because they are based on
assumptions about what is ultimately
real I mean if you think the crystals
are going to heal you in some way it's
probably because you think that crystals
are attuned to the universe or that the
human body reflects the universe or
things like that and those are
metaphysical views it's not a
philosophical metaphysics because it
just assumes
certain thing to be true it's not
investigating it it's just sort of
assuming it and going from so help yeah
a little bit okay yeah a lot of these I
know what you mean like the meaning of
everything is still kind of abstract
yeah a lot of these things it takes
quite a few examples to make them hit
home and this is where Plato I think is
actually not a helpful person Indian one
respect because what does Plato always
have Socrates saying don't give me a
bunch of examples I don't know what the
thing actually is well how do we get our
hug we wrap our heads around this room
exam tassels right and if you actually
look at Plato
how does Plato get as ideas across he
uses a lot of exam yeah Madison and
carpentry and things like that okay so I
mean let me stop that right there and
then we'll start with today so that's a
good question